you ever get used to distending Ovation
because I'm sure it's gonna happen
tonight as well
um but we shall see but it's
um
it can be an overwhelming feeling
um
and if it only happens a few times
that's enough
that is Brendan Fraser talking to
reporters on the red carpet at the BFI
London Film Festival premiere of his new
film the whale and you know what is so
great the standing ovation happened
again yes
so well deserved the actor was brought
to tears again after the screening when
the film received a five-minute Standing
Ovation with some audiences members
saying they had Deja Vu from the warm
reception tweeting am I at Venice five
minute standing ovation for Brendan
Fraser's Masterpiece performance in the
whale he had the crowd in the palm of
their hand the entire movie my heart is
in my throat with another sharing I have
never seen a standing ovation at London
Film Festival but Brendan Fraser just
blew the roof off and in the film
directed by Darren Aronofsky Brendan
plays a 600 pound gay man confined to a
wheelchair the psychological drama sees
his character trying to reconnect with
his estranged daughter after abandoning
his family for his lover and with all
this Film Festival love Morgan I know
you have thoughts on this do you think
Brendan has a shot at the Oscar oh
absolutely I mean he will hands down be
nominated for an Oscar and I'm gonna say
this now listen I haven't seen every
single movie out there every single
performance by an actor but I can't
imagine anyone else is going to deliver
performance quite like this this really
reminds me of Darren aronofsky's film
The Wrestler with Mickey Rourke Mickey
Rourke you know was a big deal in the
80s and then you know a lot of Life
happened to keep you know stepped out of
the Limelight this was his comeback film
the film itself was good but people
weren't talking about how great the film
was they were talking about Mickey
rourke's performance yeah and I was
rooting for him I know he got nominated
for an Oscar I know he didn't win I was
so devastated for him um so this
actually feels like a very similar story
with Brendan Frazier I mean obviously he
was like the hero to all of us in the
90s for us 90s kids growing up and then
he he disappeared from Hollywood and you
know he he's had some tough times and
he's been very open about that recently
and so I think we're all like rooting
for him but put all that aside his
performance is incredible I did not know
he could act like that it's so emotional
not my favorite film I'll be honest
about that but his performance hands
down I think it's Oscar winning well his
you know his reaction to all of this and
I know this from you know spending a
little bit of time with him at Film
Festival here in Toronto yeah you
interviewed him the red carpet I mean
he's taken aback by everything and he
doesn't you know it's really interesting
seeing him move through this because he
doesn't move through this the same way a
lot of other actors
um do when they get these sorts of
accolades they know he's kind of a claim
he seems a little bit like uh like he
doesn't exactly know what to do with all
of it yeah like he's like are you is
this real like are you are you being
honest like you're almost like yes we
love you yeah when it comes to the idea
about him uh being at the Academy Awards
and perhaps eventually getting up on
that stage and speaking at that Podium
if you know if this happens to pass uh
it's to me it's such an interesting
Visual and such an interesting story
because laid out exactly the way you
laid it out his story of the last couple
of decades
um and this being his sort of comeback
performance imagine the standing ovation
that night oh I mean I think I'll be
sobbing if I just want him to get
nominated I I I'm not usually someone
who's like they're going to get a
nomination but he's going to get
nominated for sure and just seeing him
at the Oscars would just bring so much
joy to my life love that for him yeah